speaking what's up on Twitter stuff has
been happening Twitter I mean yeah
YouTube every single YouTube community
seems to be on fire we're doing pretty
well they're anime YouTube right now
surprisingly I mean yeah it's kind of
wild right now nobody want to get into
the specifics of all yeah it's all
speculation I'm sure you guys have a
Twitter account
you know what's basically the whole of
YouTube's on fire and every day you log
in on Twitter it's just it is just the
fire yeah yeah yeah I mean it's just and
this one is just like exhausting right
it's so hard to keep up with and I
obviously don't to sit here and be like
you know you know [ __ ] the victims or
whatever I'm not trying to say that what
we know I'm trying to say is that it's
so exhausting as like I don't know as is
shall I say consumer or just person on
the internet there's just too much
information for me to be able to keep up
with everything that's going on now yeah
there's only so many Twitter long as I
can read in a day before I just start to
the big sigh yeah yeah I want to care
right I want to support all these people
yeah we are coming out with all the
statements but I also don't want to like
help a situation that I don't understand
anything about yeah yeah exactly
and then also this just this is too many
like it feels like our brains are being
like ddosed right now yeah it's like
well only is the world ending with
coronavirus which we've just forgot
about yeah like you know we're gonna
deal with all this [ __ ] that's it and
figure that out and it's just oh my god
it's impossible like I don't even know
how the drama channels are keeping up
with all the stuff that's coming yeah
they're just frothing at the mouth our
base content
I mean I made a joke on Twitter saying
like the only people benefiting from
2020 all the drama in news channels but
it really does seem that's the case you
know yeah everybody else is just so sick
and I feel I just wish it didn't happen
it's tragic that the bar for being a
semi-decent content creator is just not
touching kids now it's just keeping your
genitals yeah yeah you know it's sad
that it's come to that you know all
right I guess we're just making content
is not even a thing anymore
remember like five years ago when it was
controversial to have a sponsor in your
video and now it's kind of controversial
if you do something really weird with
kids yes just like what's I don't know I
mean I mean I mean YouTube's changed and
evolved so much it's I mean thinking
thinking about just just like I'm going
going on like a Content perspective yeah
yeah you know I mean there's there's
always this kind of like YouTube matter
about the content you should make cuz I
remember like commentary channels or
drama channels didn't really exist like
five years ago because what what like I
don't know cuz I remember it I remember
thinking why would anyone be interested
in YouTube was talking about other
youtubers I guess it's like the way that
you know the reason why TMZ exists right
like yeah yeah it gets to a point right
where YouTube got so big and you can
only like that people I mean I basically
only watch you at this point
yeah yeah no matter what's the Netflix
but it's like 80% YouTube right Wow yeah
it would make sense that then a market
would appear for being able to just talk
about issues yeah at youtuber drama dumb
[ __ ] that youtubers do this my god do
they do don't some dumb [ __ ]
yeah and a lot of them unfortunately get
away with a lot of it yeah and I think
it's just because there was not as many
eyes on just what youtubers were doing
back then cuz it was just like why are
you talking about youtuber that they're
not a celebrity they don't have any
power well you know as much as all these
youtubers I don't know like Twitter has
just been I've always enjoyed Twitter
because I've always said to people it's
kind of a nice in-between of social and
business at least in terms of Layton as
a youtuber using Twitter mm-hmm I don't
understand what like a regular person
would be Twitter for all right I think
it's a cesspit i know i never used
twitter before you know i think as a
youtuber you it's kind of you have no
choice
it's almost required at this point yeah
next to a YouTube channel I mean I doubt
many we would be friends right if we
didn't yeah to me Twitter is just
basically Facebook for you know for
influencers online I guess like I get to
follow what everyone else is doing yeah
basically no just in my own
circles but in like other circles as
well because that's basically the only
reason I go on Twitter apart from ludes
and means you don't I mean the rest of
Twitter just makes me sometimes you know
what I mean you know and I mean you
can't debate anything really on Twitter
not not and people aren't interested in
having like that but the moment you join
in on an argument you've already lost
that's why like you know I obviously we
all world human we all have opinions on
things yeah I think the reason why most
of us just don't comment on anything cuz
it's like you if you comment you lose
yeah get involved you lose we copy
[ __ ] means the waste of energy it's
like if I wanted to get involved I don't
think Twitter is the right platform get
involved like a lot of things like some
things gear definitely but I feel like
there are other platforms or other means
that can that you could use to get
involved and it's just like it's crazy
how even the most agreeable statements
can become controversial on Twitter like
I saw someone who is just like yeah just
like don't [ __ ] kids and there's somehow
people in the comments
somehow there was someone commenting
like you know as a playing devil's
advocate it's like what what yes just
like drink like you know a thing that
everyone should understood was the thing
to do
unfortunately cause since nowadays it's
not as common as we'd like to think it
is which is why I just again like even
if you know even if I think me
commenting on something or like you know
getting involved with the drama is like
a slam dunk I'm like it's not worth it
cuz even like for people who are like I
don't know like you could say you got a
drink water to survive and people would
be like but I like drinking coke yeah I
know are you telling me that I can't
drink coke you [ __ ] right-wing